what is life like for you right now in
quarantine is it just you and the bird
it's just me the bird a couple of homies
a girl wait who's this girl quarantining
with you you know
you threw it out there i did say that
pretty early on
huh the last time i talked to you that
you had made a list
of what you wanted oh my god i did tell
you that
this is from my future wife just like
try to check as many of these boxes as
you can
girlfriend qualities with confidence
intelligence opinionated
empathetic self-aware active listener
sexual deviant she got to be a sexual
deviant tell me you don't want your wife
to be a sexual deviant come on
guy talented worldly
she's gotta have foresight and she gotta
be insightful then
you were hanging out with josie conseco
like
a few weeks after that so what
happened there is she's a girl that's
staying with you
yeah it is her you
i mean
okay wait walk me through how this
happened you walk with me
you you're the one that told me all of
this i know but something i do is
exploit the [ __ ] out of my life and i
don't know if i'm ready to exploit that
part of it just yet
okay well can i play you a message from
somebody
uh yeah it's from your brother actually
oh
okay hey logan it's me your brother
hi uh me and the rest of the world want
to know
are you single who are you dating
tell us i know there's somebody i think
i can't i can't i can either confirm
or the name you already confirmed it
he knows i don't know why he's like how
did you get him to do that he was with
me
i didn't even i just said will you tape
a message that i could blame and that's
what he chose to ask you
i mean what do you want from me you know
i'm i'm just we just want to know
i just want to live assemble nor my life
but normal alive
but it's hard because i put everything
on camera so some things i try
i try just a little bit to keep to
myself
yeah that's fair then one more thing
about it does
she does she check off all the things on
your list that you gave to me nope
she doesn't no what girl that
the list i described is a unicorn and i
realized this
relationships are about compromise if
you if you have a checklist
and the person that you're with checks
off every single box
i mean good for you i envy that person
that is insane
i think the idea the idea is to get a
relationship and grow with the person
as they develop traits that you're
attracted to
yeah so while while she definitely
checks out the majority for sure
you know just like me we both got stuff
to work on yeah
how did you meet her i think just like
the crossing of la circles like it was
like a venn diagram you know like i'm
over here she's over here and then we
went like this one night
yeah is it serious
serious it is
it's pretty serious yeah full
transparency if if you get
if you're a woman and you get tied up in
my life
like your life will never be the same
it will just not um the association the
things you see
here the things you experience here
being around
me the way my mind works like
it's it once you're involved in my life
it is a whirlwind
it is a is it is a chaotic monsoon
of xyz and so i'm i'm
hesitant to involve the person that i'm
spending my time with as much
as i do everything else uh
for the sake of them in their life is
that like a conversation that you have
with them yeah for sure yeah that's good
that you at least have that conversation
and you're
like on the same page about it yeah i do
now because i wasn't i didn't i didn't
realize it until
my last relationship where i was like
wow whoa
this had serious repercussions
yeah yeah yeah like
like it's just you say the name you say
the name logan paul or like jake paul
and
depending on what room you're in some
people get like a
shiver down their spine you know like it
like just the sound of it is like hold
on
those kids oh whoa and i totally get it
we've done some
some really good questionable non-good
life decisions
um and and i just want i want
people to be aware of what they're
getting into before they before they get
into it
you're not moving across the country
with the guy we've never met
you have this shiny bright perfect life
i don't know how to fit into this um
well then let's talk about valley girl
because i watched it
oh boy hi coming out in three days it
was great
you do kind of play this jock in the
movie you play mickey
hey mickey yeah your fine is basically
your
song in this movie yeah um
how would you describe him like is he a
jerk does he have good qualities
do you um mickey's he's ignorant he's
ignorant but
he's got good intentions his delivery
hey this is actually just like me in
real life his delivery sometimes needs a
little bit of work
he's he's a fun loving ignorant immature
kid but his intention
is good and you have to keep that in
mind when you take into account
how fun was it to uh to wear those
outfits to get your hair done like that
every day
so so that's a great question going to
set was awesome i
i loved all the casts i loved dressing
up and pretending i was in the 80s like
my parents
even the the songs was like i i i love
music from the 80s yeah the soundtrack
is amazing
it sounds awesome the soundtrack is
awesome and i think the movie ends
really really strong like i actually get
like somewhat emotional towards the end
maybe because i was there on set and the
movie has so much like
weight in real life for me yeah um
but yeah it was amazing the one bad
thing i don't know if you
noticed my character as a mullet mickey
bowen has a mullet
and i also had a mullet in real life so
it was all fun and games until i left
set to go back to the real world
what 2018 and i'm walking around with a
mullet hanging down on my shoulders